[Music]
all right our next show also involves
three kids but these are some real
spoiled brats so good luck to Kaitlin
Olson who is totally unprepared to take
care of them in the mix what about this
woman named Mickey who comes from you
know the wrong side of the tracks and
she's a hustler and she needs money so
she asks her sister I want to give you
an opportunity to invest their concern
but then as soon as she's definitely
five minutes and then the FBI raids the
place your reward for the arrest of
Christopher and Pamela Pemberton I need
you to watch the kids tonight I get left
to taking care of the kids
you know Caitlin from It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia where she's the angry
and drunken sweet Dee now she's the
hard-living Mick ETR lines
Ashley crossing got a behind-the-scenes
look at the new Fox comedy and found out
everything you need to know the
character that's why Jimmy is basically
the old dog that Mickey brings with her
to this brave new world he considers
himself my long-term boyfriend but I do
not okay I played chip Pemberton uh kind
of very entitled I play Sabrina his big
sister she spends most of her time
trying to make Mickey's life hell I'm
good I just felt kind of funny for a
second honey like you just drank six
different types of sleep medication
honey well my character is Alba and she
takes care of the Pemberton children
don't worry I will clean this up what
was it about this show that made you
fall in love with it you know I love
it's always sunny and they don't really
ever want that to end and I was able to
do both of them and it's nice to be able
to do a network show that my family can
watch have you brought them to set yeah
here a lot we can actually sit in this
time rather than just be in my trailer
which they are on Sonny thank you can't
come on this side because is it you when
I have a break
[Music]
you